so donald trump's press briefings in
general have become completely beyond
parody they often start 15
30 45 60 70 minutes late
never with an explanation completely
disrespectful to members of the press
and to to to the audience quite frankly
um and that's sort of part and parcel of
how we've observed donald trump behave
his entire presidency
yesterday donald trump held one of these
press briefings outside the white house
i guess because it was a nice day and he
made no sense
and he said outrageously crazy things
that should serve to remind us
every single day every single one of us
that he has to go
he must go it's time let's look at some
of the completely
humiliating and depraved moments donald
trump first of all furious that people
were wearing masks
donald trump demanded that jeff mason
take off his mask
before he would accept a question from
the jeff of what happens when you were
in france continues to be a school
you're gonna have to take that off
please
just you can take it off your your
health how many feet are you away i'll
speak a lot
well if you don't take it off you're
very muffled
so if you would take it off would be a
lot easier i'll just speak a lot louder
is that better
it's better yeah it's better mr
president
trump does not like those masks remember
no one at his huge rally last week in
latrobe pennsylvania
was wearing a mask trump doing another
rally tonight will there be masks
reportedly not
later one reporter did actually
pull his mask down or off before asking
a question
trump praised him for not wearing a mask
do you um
you sound so clear as opposed to
everybody else where they refuse
your tweets about the 16-19 projects
what a great leader right
really leading by example during a
pandemic criticizing those wearing masks
and praising those
not wearing masks and so after we got
past the mask
triggering donald trump again talking
about
all of the crimes that barack obama and
joe biden supposedly committed against
him
usa today my question is about the
durham report which you have talked
about recently
you said let's see what happens now
you've accused people of committing
crimes against you during the russia
investigation
yeah sure they spied on my campaign
that's right they spotted my campaign
and if they were democrats they would
have been in jail two years ago
they would have been in jail literally
if this side were
the democrats said they would have been
in jail two years ago for 50-year terms
for treason and other things
my question is do you want the justice
department to indict people over this
i'm not going to say that i have to see
the report i haven't see i purposely
i don't know if that was a good thing
smart thing i don't know
but nobody can complain about it i have
every right to have been very much
involved and maybe someday i'll get
involved in it
they spied on my campaign and that
includes biden and obama
now remember that we are still waiting
on exactly
which laws barack obama broke which
crimes did joe biden commit but in the
meantime trump believes that
50 years in prison for each of them
obama and biden would be right
this is crazy this is even crazier than
trump saying to hillary
during the debates in 2016 you'd be
locked up
if i were president a ton of questions
during yesterday's
press briefing related to of course this
blockbuster story
about donald trump allegedly referring
to troops who died in combat
as losers and suckers trump denied
reports that it was his choice not to
visit a military cemetery in france
is that we had the worst weather i think
it was as bad a rain as i've just about
ever seen
and it was a fog you literally couldn't
see i walked out i didn't have
i didn't need somebody to tell me i
walked out i said there's no way we can
take helicopters in this i understand
helicopters very well
and they said no sir that's been
canceled they would have had to go
secret service i have the whole list
they would have had to go through a very
very busy section
during the day of paris
they would have had to go through the
city yeah uh
now of course this story already
widely corroborated abundantly cleared
that it tracks with what donald trump
was willing to say publicly
and had been saying publicly for years
including about john mccain
and then again donald trump denies
reports that he disparaged fallen u.s
troops and it's a disgrace who would say
a thing like that only an animal would
say a thing like that
there's nobody that has more respect for
not only our military but for people
that gave their lives in the military
there's nobody and i think john kelly
knows that i think he would know that i
think he
knows that from me remember trump
publicly said
about john mccain he prefers soldiers
who don't get captured
and the topic of john mccain actually
came up
and trump if you can imagine this said
he should be praised
trump demanding credit for not ruining
john mccain's funeral
believing your denials of the atlantic
story because of what you said about
john mccain in the past
do you understand that and have you
asked no i don't understand have you
asked john kelly to refute
that story no i don't understand it at
all no because
i've always been on the opposite side of
john mccain john mccain like wars
i will be a better warrior than anybody
but will we fight it where we're going
to win them
and frankly i was never a fan of john
mccain you know that that's been very
obvious i was
but i had to approve his entire funeral
i wanted him to get he deserved
a first place you know it all was
approved by me we sent air force one to
pick up the casket a lot of things but
no i was not a fan of john mccain see
guys
none of it can be true because trump
didn't ruin john mccain's fuhrer funeral
and he could have
trump could have ruined john mccain's
funeral and he didn't do it
trump then going on to say that his most
sophisticated friends
by the way who are trump's sophisticated
friends
trump's sophisticated friend said to him
he must be the most innocent person ever
to be president
be the most innocent honorable man
ever to hold the office of president
think of it they spent just
mueller alone he spent i guess the real
number turned out to be 48 million
dollars but whatever it was many many
millions of dollars
they had 18 angry democrats looking
they had fbi agents all over the place
they had every and they have no
collusion friends of mine have said
sophisticated friends have said you've
got to be the most innocent guy
ever to hold this office and there's a
lot of truth to that yeah thank you mr
president
donald trump genuinely seems to believe
that he is completely innocent i i
have gone back back and forth about this
over time
i actually believe trump is so
delusional that he really does
think he's done nothing wrong ever and
that there is
some kind of witch hunt against him i
used to think maybe trump was just
saying it i now believe trump actually
believes it
confirming his total disconnect from
reality
and then donald trump asked about his
postmaster general lewis de joy
there are now multiple investigations
into louis de joy
there is speculation that louis de joy
has committed multiple crimes
and donald trump just plays dumb and
says he hasn't really heard too much
about it
mr president if proven true are you okay
with postmaster general
the joy and the fact that he asked
former employees as private company
to make donations to the gop and then
reimburse them
are you okay i don't know too much about
it i read something this morning but i
don't other than that i have to see it
uh
he's very respected man he was approved
very much uh by both parties i guess it
was sort of a
an approval that took place by both
parties i don't know
exactly what the story is i'll certainly
know within a short period of time
i just read it for the first time i read
it this morning just like you did would
you support an investigation
sir sure sure and i think let the
investigations
go but but uh he's a very respected man
again it was a bipartisan commission
postmaster general is appointed by a
bipartisan commission
and we'll see how that goes but no i i
think he's a very honest guy but we'll
see
yeah less yeah trump never seems to have
heard about anything that might be bad
for him
and then lastly donald trump wrapping up
with casual xenophobia as i like to call
it
after not directly answering a single
question
well i want to thank you all and i just
want to wish you a very happy labor day
and we're having tremendous success
whether it's on the vaccines whether
it's on the pandemic
the the plague that came in from china
the china should have never let happen
because i will never feel the same about
china and i just want to again wish you
a happy labor day thank you very much
everybody
so again are these benefiting trump
does trump benefit from doing these
press briefings
or is it just doing more self-inflicted
damage i don't
know how many trump has watched this
stuff political observers watch it
uh but they're already mostly decided i
don't think any votes are changing as a
result of that
media outlets cover the highlights
but are these really helping trump in
any way that's what i want to hear from
you about
we'll have more clips and coverage of
this press briefing
and tonight's rally by the way that
donald trump will be doing
um on our instagram page at david pakman
show make sure you're following us there
and make sure you're following me at
david.pakman as well
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors sussman
and han sussman and han has everything
you need when it comes to face masks and
other protective gear for covid19
and they're giving my audience 20
percent off sussman and han is the
company
that i personally have been going to for
face masks
i love and trust the products they sell
that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i have tried
tons of different masks this year and i
still have not found a mask
that's more comfortable or easier to
breathe in than the washable cotton
masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cotton
that feels great on your skin
it has convenient adjustable straps it
features a disposable five layer
particle filter made of activated carbon
they also have disposable cloth masks
which are really comfortable as well as
other gear
like face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love sussman and han
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions they're
a great company
you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is underneath this video
and you can save
20 off of everything in their store
when you use the coupon code david